non-minimalists
eric has a question here i recently let
go
of religion but i don't know what to
cling to
next that's an interesting word there i
don't know what to cling
to next was that maybe the problem the
clinging
i think the problem is religion maybe
just maybe go back to faith okay let's
talk a little bit about that because
so i i'll give you my pithy answer that
we can unpack a little bit but
uh progress is measured by our ability
to let go
and i think what happens right now is we
cling to something whatever it is it
could be a religion
whatever we're clinging to there's this
great quote from david foster wallace
from infinite jest he said everything
i've ever let go of has call marks on it
well that's not letting go at all that's
just being
dragged until you drop so let's talk
about this faith versus religion thing
i'm fascinated by that
well let me just give my quick response
let's do it
and as long as you're looking for
something to cling to you have not let
go of religion
because religion is an external
construct that gives your life meaning
and leaves you feeling meaningless
and so i i think that there's something
internal inside of
his struggle that he doesn't believe he
can become so he has to actually put on
like i i don't clean i don't turn to
religion
and to give me what i'm searching for
and aaron you talked about different
religion and faith maybe you should pop
in there
it's been a huge conversation i think
with our whole lifetime because i'm
wildly ocd so everything for me was i
mean i was the catholic inside of our
christian family of like repeating the
same prayer every single day
and you grew up roman catholic and so
definitely religiously ocd
and so you helped me kind of understand
going okay it's okay to be ocd and
struggle with rep
repetitive nature of prayer of doing xyz
but
finding a real relationship in faith is
very different i think than
being living by the demands of religion
going like this is your guilt or your
shame is so tied to whether you achieve
or you don't or you do this and you do
that
and you're absolved of your sin versus
this faith going like hey there's a god
who wants to know you
there's something out there the creative
director of the universe if you want to
call it that once that created you and
wants to know you
and that's a different type of
relationship that i don't think
sells to mass media people religion
worked because people
were meant to be controlled by certain
people i think people have that ideology
and so
faith for me is is so much more of a
relationship that
that you understand and you listen and
you learn and you talk and you are in an
engaged relationship but
that's what i got yeah no i uh one i i
think there's something
looking to you to be more quotable no no
i i'm not trying to be quotable right
now i'm
i was i don't you're allowed to edit
things
[Laughter]
we've got a few pithy things we're good
to go let's just expand on it no
the reason is one i i feel like we
we're whenever we're driven by guilt or
shame
we end up in religion when we're
driven by intention uh and meaning
we're more likely to find something
inherently healthy
and you know so like i don't feel a need
to try to convert anyone and i'm a
pastor
i i have a i have a desire to help
people
live the full life they're created to
live and
and when a person tells me man i've let
go of religion but i'm looking for
something to hold on to
i need some institution outside of me to
fix the world
yeah it's almost childish you know
infantile it is
and and i'm only saying this because i'm
inherently an anarchist i mean i was i
that that's who i was growing up that's
i never trust institutions i did not
trust religion i did not trust
governments
um what i would i trust is um the power
of
your internal world to shape and create
the world around you
and you if if you're filled with anger
or
greed or violence or envy you're gonna
create a destructive world if you're
filled with hope
and love and intention
and purpose you're going to create a
better world and
and so i would say look i i don't know
who you are and where you are on your
life journey
but um one i do believe in god and
obviously i am a person who believes in
a personal relationship with jesus
but what i'd say to you is um
look for the change within you and move
toward whatever
moves you toward love move toward
whatever moves you toward hope
like the the best internal compass is
when
all the right essentials begin to be
created inside of you
like i would not be a follower of jesus
if somehow it moved me away from love
if it moved me away from hope if it
moved me away from compassion
like i think that we all have this
internal compass and if we pay attention
to it
it'll move us in the right direction
i get i'm used to this my mind's blown
and my insides are so
inspired right now the the the love
thing is fascinating because i also find
some value
uh in whether it's religion or whatever
there's this sort of liturgical nature
of religion where people
find some sort of structure right and i
think that's what he's looking
for right now specifically and what
you're saying is that whatever that
structure
ends up being it needs to be predicated
on love
not on a set of particular rituals that
are going to
drive you toward love necessarily and
it's just like with injury i've had a
lot of injuries in my life because i
love
playing sports and at first i mean when
i came out the knee surgery they gave me
this massive metal brace
to put on my knee and these really cool
crutches and
and uh i walked out of the hospital i
took the brace off and i put the
crutches down and i started walking
this within the same hour of having the
surgery
and and and my family's like why did you
just say because
the braces there to protect you from
injury but it actually also reduces
your capacity to be strength stronger
and religion is a brace
love is the strength